et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Stéphane Le Foll bonjour Stéphane
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
vous êtes le maire socialiste du Mans et
vous publiez cette tribune sociale
démocratie j'écris ton nom dont on va
évidemment parler dans cette interview
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse régionale représentée par Fabrice
wesser Redon du groupe hébra les
journaux régionaux de l'Est de la France
bonjour Fabrice
du côté de la Russie votre ville du Mont
est jumelée avec la ville de Rostov un
temps envahi par Wagner ce week-end
qu'elle regarde vous portez sur ce
putsch avorter de prix gaugine le chef
de Wagner qui a défié Poutine avant de
renoncer est-ce que Poutine en serai
pour vous
ce qui a été frappant c'est que pendant
pratiquement une journée entière une
milice même si elle est importante avec
25000 hommes a pris une ville depuis un
million d'habitants siège du
commandement des forces
qui sont sur la frontière et en Ukraine
et que pendant une journée
monsieur Prigogine a été en mesure
de laisser penser qu'il allait boire
rouler jusqu'à Moscou
et rien n'indiquer qu'il y avait en face
quelque chose qui pouvait se passer donc
moi c'est ça qui m'a frappé cette espèce
de de de d'État suspendu ou un homme
Prigogine fait des déclarations ou
Vladimir continuerait répondre puis
après on a l'impression qu'il se passe
rien qui a plus des tas qui a pu et que
la faiblesse de Poutine
ça montre ce qui est que derrière tout
ça on sait pas trop si c'est simplement
deux clans qui s'affrontent mais où est
l'état oui ce que doit être et ce qui
est souvent représenté je crois qu'on
regarde ce qui se passe au Kremlin dans
ses grands défis militaires avec ces
bataillons qui défilent
là il y a quand même quelque chose qui
s'est passé et qui est assez surprenant
et qui donc conduit clairement à une
faiblesse et un affaiblissement du
pouvoir de Poutine dans votre tribune
sociale démocratie j'écris ton nom vous
dites l'attitude autocentrée du
président Macron a de graves
conséquences en politique étrangères sur
le conflit ukrainien il y a eu des
oscillations entre positions conciliante
avec la Russie et position pro
ukrainiennes à la crédibilité de la
France pour vous le chef de l'État dans
beaucoup de domaines cet exemple là sur
des phrases qui étaient incomprises au
moment où justement on voyait bien que
l'agression de la Russie était clair il
faut pas humilier la Russie ou souvenez
ce que ça a donné comme interrogation
pourquoi dire ça à ce moment-là et puis
passer ensuite à une position pro
ukrainienne
voyage en Chine retour dans l'avion
position
ambiguë et incomprise aussi par rapport
à Taïwan on a sur l'Afrique le sujet du
rejet aujourd'hui de la France et de son
recul et ce qui est un vrai sujet il y a
eu avec les États-Unis cette partie de
tape dans le dos avec Trump puis après
on finit avec Biden et puis la claque
sur les sous-marins australiens donc la
crédibilité du pays prenons aussi
l'exemple du Liban ou Emmanuel Macron
est parti au dedans annonçant qui avait
renversé la table politique et puis à la
fin il se passe rien il y a donc une
déception vis-à-vis de la France
qu'est-ce que je dis je dis que comme en
politique nationale il veut tout faire
il y a plus de diplomatie d'ailleurs qui
connaît le nom du ministre ou de la
ministre en l'occurrence des Affaires
étrangères personne du temps de Hollande
c'était Fabius Laurent Fabius une
personnalité politique qui a géré la
diplomatie et qui nous a amené sur
plusieurs grands sujets à trouver des
accords je pense à l'accord de Vienne
avec l'Iran je pense bien sûr à la COP
s'il y a pas une grande diplomatie il
peut pas y avoir d'internationalistes et
de construction
il a ce côté systématiquement de se
mettre avec tape dans le dos poignée de
main viril là le dernier étape qui n'est
pas mauvaise en soi en terme d'objectif
d'aller chercher du financement à
l'échelle international parce que la
planète on la sauvera pas tout seul ça
c'est un message très fort et
l'internationalisme d'aujourd'hui c'est
celui qui doit porter comme objectif de
sauver la planète mais tout seul on
réunit du monde bien sûr mais après ce
qui va se passer c'est ça le problème et
c'est celui là que je j'essaye
d'expliquer et je considère que si on
doit revenir au gouvernement c'est avec
une ligne internationaliste et une
diplomatie renforcée
national Oriane à connotation mondiale
planétaire la dissolution de la semaine
dernière des soulèvements de la terre le
gouvernement a fait le choix de
dissoudre purement et simplement
cette organisation sous aviez été aux
affaires vous auriez procédé de la même
manière alors après on se met toujours
dans la situation arriver à la décision
telle qu'elle a été prise le vrai sujet
depuis longtemps et c'est un sujet pour
la gauche la violence quand elle est
considérée comme justifié ne peut que en
contrepartie
justifier aussi d'autres violences moi
j'ai toujours été clair dans la
condamnation de la violence et je vois
bien que dans le débat à gauche en
particulier encore des gens qui
justifient au nom de la cause que l'on
défend qui est une cause juste mais ça
dépend de quel point de vue bien sûr
qu'elle est juste pour ceux qui la
défendent et puis elle peut être
incomprise pour nous pour certains
l'activisme et la violence
ne peuvent se justifier sauf à
considérer qu'on est en dehors d'un état
de droit et qu'à un moment il faut faire
autrement que c'est par justement l'acte
violent par la contestation violente
qu'on peut arriver à renverser ou à
changer les choses si on considère ça
c'est un choix stratégique et politique
moi je considère qu'à partir de là on
tourne le dos à l'étroit et à la
démocratie après ce que fait une partie
de la gauche pour vous mais ce que fait
une partie de la gauche quand je vois je
passe en réunion Rousseau ou d'autres
qui ont justifié par exemple quand
monsieur boudin se fait agresser on met
dans le même dans le même dans le même
condamne quand même l'agression d'un élu
puis on dit en même temps oui mais c'est
justifié parce que c'est de la faute à
Emmanuel Macron et puis parce qu'il agit
pas suffisamment bon écoutez c'est où
c'est pas justifié ou c'est
injustifiable et à ce moment-là on peut
pas voir deux poids de vieux alors pour
ce qui est une solution ça c'est un
autre sujet
ça justifié une dissolution
moi je n'aurais là a priori comme ça au
moment où a été décidé la dissolution
c'est plus un acte politique que je moi
je ne partage pas je pense pas que c'est
comme ça mais sur la question de la
violence et depuis déjà pas mal de temps
il y a un manque de clarté du côté de la
gauche qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on a une
difficulté à s'expliquer et là
démocratie ça se défend l'État de droit
ça se défend la revendication ça se
défend le fait qu'on soit contre ça doit
s'exprimer bien entendu mais quand on
choisit la voie systématique de la
violence et qu'on cherche à la justifier
faut pas s'étonner après qui est
d'audience voilà moi c'est ce que je
pense et c'est pour ça que j'ai toujours
été très clair sur ces questions-là
parvenir sous la police tue enfin bon
voilà il y a un moment
républicain début de sortie de l'État
droit chez Jean-Luc Mélenchon
il y a une pensée
qui justifie puisque je vais revenir
pour être précis c'est écrit la cause
justifie la violence si la cause
justifie elle le lance ça veut dire que
la violence c'est justifiable si elle
est justifiable à ce moment-là on est
hors le cadre démocratique l'État de
droit
puisque vous êtes mère je voudrais vous
faire agir sur ce qui s'est passé la
semaine dernière le gouvernement qui
cherche des économies 10 milliards ont
été annoncés lors d'assise de finances
publiques que les associations d'élus
ont décidé de boycotter elles ont eu
raison c'est une bonne solution la
politique de la chaise vide c'est
toujours la même chose est-ce qu'il y a
une concertation avant est-ce que sur
les décisions qui ont été prises et qui
concerne les collectivités il y a une
concertation il n'a pas eu et pas une
discussion qu'est-ce qui peut se passer
quand on peut faire je regarde un sujet
majeur pour moi celui du logement je
voyais de la construction quand
j'entends monsieur Attal promouvoir des
baisses d'impôts sur les classes
moyennes
débat qu'on peut avoir politique je sais
pas combien ça va coûter mais pendant ce
temps là la construction de logements ne
cesse de chuter on est à des niveaux les
plus bas alors j'entendais Monsieur le
Maire qui disait mais bon les taux
d'intérêt augmente donc il faut accepter
de temps en temps que le marché se
réajuste non non le marché ne se
réajuste pas il y a une politique
aujourd'hui par exemple qui vise à
séparer la France entre les zones
tendues les zones non tendues le
résultat de tout ça c'est qu'aujourd'hui
dans les zones tendues il y a plus de
fonciers donc on construit plus et dans
les zones non tendues on a aucune aucune
aucun soutien à la construction résultat
on est à 150000 logements par an 200
alors qu'on devrait être à 500 ou 600
000 donc cette politique du logement
plutôt que de annoncer des baisses
d'impôts il devrait y avoir quand même
une réflexion et un changement complet
de cette politique c'est si un échec
dans le domaine des deux caca du premier
quinquennat et de la suite du second
franchement
c'est une catastrophe
autre le sujet vous connaissez Marlène
Chapat puisqu'elle a été consciemment
principal du Mans elle est dans le
viseur de la commission d'enquête
sénatoriale sur le fond Marianne qui a
été créé après l'assassinat
j'ai vu les deux sénateurs qui étaient à
la tête de cette commission j'ai eu le
rapporteur justement des dessinateurs
qui dit qu'elle n'a pas dit la vérité
elle doit démissionner vers vous non
mais ça alors excuse-moi démissionner ce
que doit pas démissionner c'est pas le
débat
connaissez concerne municipale lorsque
tu as été considéré adjointe même hein
donc moi j'étais pas présent à ce
moment-là autant que je le sautais donc
quand et quand je suis revenu après
avoir été ministre et bien c'est elle
qui est parti et qui était devenue
ministre bon donc moi je suis pas de
jugement à porter sur se porter sur ce
qu'elle a fait sur cette affaire ce qui
s'est passé c'est la commission
d'enquête qui a été très claire de
laisser penser ou de laisser croire que
c'était de la faute des autres et que
elle était simplement dans l'impulsion
et qu'il y avait rien à voir j'ai été
ministre je sais même ce que c'est qu'un
cabinet ou alors on le dirige où on le
dirige pas là c'est un autre sujet mais
ça veut dire qu'il y a une partie
d'incompétence ou une partie qui alors
je laisse le rapporteur qui a dit ce
qu'il a dit c'est lui qui a mené cette
enquête amené ses débats donc mais moi
ça me semble être complètement
contradictoire avec ce que doit être la
responsabilité qui va avec celle de
ministre alors on n'est pas responsable
de tout parce qu'il se passe tellement
de choses qu'on peut pas être tout mais
là sur des sujets aussi politiques où on
choisit après un événement tragique
puisque c'est l'assassinat de Samuel
Paty de faire un choix sur le l'idée
qu'il faut promouvoir défendre penser la
laïcité il y a des choix qui sont faits
et comme par hasard non c'est pas moi
qui les ai fait non là il y a un vrai
problème
d'incompétence dans le sens où quand on
est ministre on peut pas laisser penser
que sur des questions aussi politiques
on a laissé d'autres choisir à sa place
ça c'est pas acceptable un dernier mot
avant de parler de votre tribune sur une
autre actualité il y avait pas de
Journal du Dimanche hier dans les
kiosques les salariés en grève pour
protester contre la nomination de
Geoffroy le jeune qui vient de Valeurs
Actuelles la mise de la culture d'y
comprendre les inquiétudes et pose cette
question pour nos valeurs républicaines
comment ne pas s'alarer est-ce qu'il y a
pas quand même une ingérence de
l'exécutive dans la rédaction d'un
journal avec ce que nous prenons avant
la gérance
hypothétique il y avait déjà eu une
question sur cnews avec la mise de la
culture je me souviens sur
elle avait plus ou moins sous-entendu
que les saisir ce qui est pulsé ça
maintenant mais l'arcom voilà bon bref
non il y a une vraie question qui est
sur le
sur le jeune valeurs actuelles c'est une
ligne
éditoriale et politique claire le choix
qui est fait par celui qui finance le
Journal du Dimanche c'est quand même
d'indiquer par ce choix la ligne qui
souhaite pour ce journal et je comprends
de ce fait pourquoi les journalistes qui
sont Journal du Dimanche ouais dans une
jolie dire dans une pluralité aussi au
sein du Journal du Dimanche puissent se
dire mais où va-t-on et qu'est-ce que
nous allons faire de notre journal
et donc là il y a une légitimité parce
que il y a un choix j'allais dire
comment je veux dire ça extrêmement
fort qui est fait par Bolloré de nommer
monsieur Lejeune très fort ça signale
qui n'envoie mais moi je comprends que
j'en ai eu ça ce sont là disent mais
nous on travaille dans quelles
conditions Olivier fort lui souhaite
légiférer sur l'indépendance des
rédactions pour qu'aucun directeurs de
rédaction de sa désigné sans la
sentiment de sa rédaction elle-même vous
êtes favorable à une telle non
le fait que une rédaction
qu'elle dalle à majorité quelle est la
majorité de la rédaction qui va pouvoir
décider il y a des questions politiques
il y a une question de financement aussi
de la presse on peut regarder comment on
assure le pluralisme mais alors là par
la loi venir directement discuter de ce
qui va se passer dans chacune des
rédactions là encore faisons attention à
pas comme dirait certain basculer de
l'autre côté du cheval hein il faut
rester sur une ligne c'est le pluralisme
qui est important c'est cette capacité
qu'on a à le faire vivre et si la
respons possibilité de l'État et du
politique est engagé c'est pour ça ça
c'est le point essentiel après à pas
aller rentrer non plus dans tous les
débats de chacune des rédactions et au
nom de quoi et pourquoi ça se ferait
attention voilà allez on va parler de
votre tribune sociale démocratie j'écris
ton nom quel est le sens de cette
tribune quel est votre définition
sociale démocratie
dans les débats qui à gauche c'est pas
simplement un débat pour ou contre la
nups c'est un débat sur qu'est-ce qu'on
va défendre à partir d'aujourd'hui quel
diagnostic qu'on tire de la société
qu'est-ce qu'on veut porter comme
message c'est ça qui me paraît important
le débat pour ou contre c'est fini c'est
le problème de la ligne quel est
l'avenir de la gauche comment on conçoit
et quand je dis la social-démocratie
c'est qu'est-ce que c'est que la
social-démocratie en fait c'est cette un
constat celui qui a une économie de
marché
si on n'est pas dans l'économie de
marché on peut discuter d'autres choses
mais si on est dans l'économie de marché
comme l'avait dit d'ailleurs il y en a
des choses pas oui à l'économie de
marché non à la société de marché ça
c'était une comment dirais-je qu'on
mettait entre ce qui est le tout
marchant et mais en même temps
l'économie d'archives ça existe si on
veut pas déconner du marché on fait
autre chose et dans une économie de
marché où il y a de la concurrence il
faut de la régulation et c'est là que la
social-démocratie qui est aujourd'hui en
Europe ce qui se pratique partout
pratiquement c'est comme ça que ça a
évolué la sucette démocratie c'est ce
qui va permettre de trouver les
médiations et les moyens de négocier les
intérêts différents de trouver les
compromis nécessaires pour avancer et
elle est d'autant plus forte aujourd'hui
cette idée là qu'à l'échelle de la
planète justement pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique c'est parce
qu'on va être capable de se mettre
autour d'une table et de trouver aussi
des compromis qu'on va changer notre
modèle de développement Stéphane Le Foll
qu'est-ce qu'elle peut redevenir une
force politique aujourd'hui compte tenu
de son éclatement en particulier en
France et c'est ce que je dis à mon
texte vous savez dans l'histoire il y a
eu des moments où il y a des forces
politiques qui ont disparu les grands
tenants du multilatéralisme et de la
paix après la Première Guerre mondiale
ils ont été balayés
je pense qu'elle ne peut pas disparaître
parce que de toute façon elle reviendra
ou alors il y a un autre modèle complet
économique social écologique que moi je
n'ai pas encore des filles ou trouver je
l'ai pas enfin je le vois pas et même
dans la contestation que peut porter par
exemple la France insoumise on sait
jamais dans quel modèle on va aller vers
quel modèle on va aller si c'est l'idée
d'un modèle autoritaire et en même temps
planificateurs d'une transition
écologique mais la contradiction c'est
ce que je dis elle est très forte au
niveau de la France
insoumise dans cette tribune vous dites
le tumulte de la France insoumise c'est
le risque de bascule dans l'agitation et
l'autoritarisme alors que c'est
l'équilibre et le sérieux qu'il faut
viser est-ce que il faut rompre
clairement aujourd'hui avec la France
insoumise vous dites le débat pour ou
contre la nuque et derrière nous il est
il est pas derrière vous c'est ce qu'il
faut que vous pour vous changer je sais
pas la question de pour ou contre c'est
qu'est-ce que dit et qu'est-ce que
propose le programme de la nuque quelle
est la
bien est-ce que le PSG on a travaillé
avec les gens vous qualifier
vous avez pas vu que dans les débats
qu'ils ont eu en interne aujourd'hui
même au sein de la nuque même au sein de
la France insoumise plutôt il y a des
contestations sur la le côté un peu
autoritaire de la direction de la France
insoumise c'est pas moi qui le dit ce
sont les gens eux-mêmes ceux qui sont à
la France insoumise aujourd'hui et puis
après beaucoup pour aller au-delà de
tout ça c'est que le fait de dire et je
le vois bien sur les trois blocs la
gauche le macronisme et l'extrême droite
si on reste uniquement dans ces blocs là
on dit mais s'il y a pas d'alliance et
si on n'est pas tous ensemble on va pas
réussir à équilibrer les forces
politiques mais c'est faux est-ce que le
PS n'est pas dans une impasse
aujourd'hui sur le fond quand on lit
votre tribune on comprend bien qu'il y a
aucune alliance possible avec la France
insoumise et en même temps est-ce qu'une
victoire est possible sans eux mais vous
comprenez pas qu'en politique c'est la
dynamique politique qui crée la victoire
vous êtes en train de partir de blocs et
vous êtes bloqué dans les bloque mais
regardez ce qui s'est passé en Ariège
politique là tout de suite elle est un
peu de côté pour la présidentielle
qu'est-ce qui se passe pour la
présidentielle alors si vous petite
explication
10%. oui mais c'est normal là la logique
de la cinquième avec la présidentielle
fait législatives derrière mais en
présidentiel 10% c'est le socle de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon à tous les débuts de
ses campagnes présidentielles les trois
fois il y a plus d'extrême gauche il a
capté la totalité rappelez-vous ce que
c'était que Arlette Laguiller et Olivier
Besançon entre 4 et 6 ça faisait 10 il a
capté cet électorat d'extrême gauche
aujourd'hui c'est 0,5 chacun vous avez
vu vous pouvez regarder chaque
présidentielle sur cette base de 10 s'il
y a pas une gauche qui s'est redéfinie
et affai qui s'affirme avec un vrai
projet qui va attirer du monde sachant
que le macronisme a occupé toute une
partie du centre gauche
faut faire plus de 10 dès le début de la
campagne si vous faites pas plus de 10
vous avez perdu la présidentielle et
après il y a le vote il y a le vote
utile qui joue donc Jean-Luc Mélenchon
joue sur ses ça c'est des atouts pour
lui plus ses qualités de tribunes
indéniable en campagne indéniable mais
ça ça ne peut pas faire une politique
qui peut faire gagner sur le front
Stéphane sur le fond je dis bien
qu'est-ce qui vous empêche de travailler
avec Olivier Faure aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
qu'il en veut je travaille avec lui
faire c'est que sur le fond qu'est-ce
que dit Olivier Faure
à part d'être toujours dans des jeux
tactiques si jamais clair je prendrai
l'exemple de chouettement de la terre
c'est de la faux alors j'ai lu le blog
enfin j'ai pas lu j'ai entendu l'autre
fois sur les quatre vérités vous l'avez
invité sur un blog où il disait que
Macron c'était ni libéralisme c'est à
dire carrément on est dans une société
pratiquement totalitaire aujourd'hui
est-ce que c'est sérieux est-ce que
quand on fait des critiques on est
obligé d'aller aussi loin dans la
caricature moi quand je dis ce que je
dis je le vois et je reviens à l'exemple
de l'Ariège le vote dans l'Ariège on a
tous dit et tout le monde avait dit vous
allez vous diviser c'est scandaleux tout
ça qu'est-ce qui s'est passé le
rassemblement national n'a pas été au
deuxième tour et la socialiste
a gagné il y a pas plus peur de gauche
hein cela dit il y a pas il y a pas plus
de terre de gauche que
regardez ce qui s'est passé dans l'Aude
un département en 2022 juste à
législative avant trois circonscriptions
qui étaient anciennement des
circonscriptions socialistes mais qui
avaient été gagnées par des LR sont
devenus rassemblement national le vrai
problème de la politique c'est qu'il
faut pas uniquement je suis pas là pour
contester les alliances il y a besoin
d'alliance mais on peut pas rester
enfermé dans un corpus et une doctrine
qui nous emmène à mon avis sur une
gauche qui s'agitent mais qui ne peut
pas gouverner
hier avait lieu Alfortville
donc de toute façon il va y avoir un
changement hier avait lieu Alfortville
le rassemblement des jeunes de la nuque
je voudrais vous faire réagir un extrait
du discours démarre à fovic c'est la
présidente des jeunes socialistes pour
parole du Parti socialiste en écoute
ce qui n'est pas sérieux c'est de
laisser des éléphants responsables de
notre chute décider de notre avenir
restez dans vos sales sombres dans vos
chuchotements nous ne voulons plus vous
entendre vous nous avez fait perdre
laissez-nous gagner
ouvrez
c'est une partie de ce que j'explique
quand on a plus de respect pour rien
on a des phrases comme ça
je voudrais lui dire que qu'elle
commence par être élu il y a des gens
qui ont beaucoup travaillé sur le
terrain pour être élu que l'expérience
s'accompte que c'est très facile de dire
dégager mais après c'est ce que j'ai
toujours dit d'ailleurs moi j'ai ça me
dérange pas de tourner une page faut-il
être capable d'en écrire une autre et là
il y a vraiment vraiment
c'est la facilité qu'est-ce qu'il y a
derrière c'est quoi le projet c'est quoi
le sujet est-ce que la désobéissance sur
les traités européens ça revient ce que
propose aujourd'hui la droite pour
l'immigration la gauche le propose pour
l'économie et le social très bien on
désobéit à l'échelle européenne c'est ce
que je dis geste d'adolescent est-ce
qu'on a pas besoin d'adultes aujourd'hui
face je le rappelle à la guerre en
Ukraine la guerre elle est pas
simplement un concept contre lequel on
doit lutter elle est là voilà donc
aujourd'hui il faut aussi des gens qui
ont de l'expérience et un peu adulte
plutôt que d'avoir des jeunes qui ont
pas beaucoup de respect voilà et ça je
pense que c'est un vrai problème dans la
société et au sein de la gauche
à Bernard Cazeneuve est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas trop divisé pour être
efficace on a il y a des personnalités
Carole Delga Bernard Cazeneuve qui est
là au moment de son discours moi il y a
de ce côté il y a des personnalités qui
ont des choses à dire moi ce que j'ai eu
envie de faire c'est de dire des choses
de dire je suis pas simplement sur
l'anti nude pour lentinux je ne suis pas
simplement contre Jean-Luc Mason parce
qu'il s'appelait Jean-Luc Mélenchon je
pense aujourd'hui et je le dis et
j'essaye de l'expliquer et de manière
très claire même sur la question
écologique ou la logique de la demande
qui est celle du projet de la nuque et
contradictoire est-ce que vous souhaitez
avoir un candidat en 2027 c'est sûr
qu'il va falloir travailler sur une
candidature mais alors mais le problème
mais non là vous vous trompez alors
après là on va retomber dans les vieux
travers de alors qui qui il y a un
problème technologies aujourd'hui je ne
sais pas si j'en se rendent compte
qu'avec le mercredi mais le en même
temps toutes les idéologies et toutes
les les lignes politiques ont disparu
regardez ce qui se passe chez les
républicains donc regardez ce qui se
passe à gauche donc le problème est
d'abord idéologique c'est ça le sujet et
c'est ce que je veux dire pourquoi
social-démocratie j'écris ton nom parce
que idéologiquement je pense qu'il faut
après avoir été sur la contestation de
la mondialisation on a besoin de revoir
et de redevenir internationaliste
ensuite pour régler le grand problème du
réchauffement climatique on a besoin
d'une grande politique d'investissement
qui désigne et rooseveltienne c'est ça
voilà
contrairement à Bernard Cazeneuve vous
êtes encore parti socialiste aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui fait que vous quitteriez
le
psy un jour on a une on n'a pas de liste
aux Européennes et conditions une ligne
politique et de la désobéissance quand
je répète une liste commune avec
puisque j'ai vu que la France insoumise
revendique l'accord de laupes la relisez
l'accord de la lipeste et vous verrez
qu'elle a désobéissant qu'est-ce que ça
signifie aujourd'hui quand on a la
guerre en Ukraine rien si ce n'est une
espèce de logique d'adolescent qui
désobéit ben moi je veux des adultes qui
travaillent pour préparer l'avenir merci
Stéphane avec nous je rappelle votre
tribune sociale démocratie j'écris ton
nom et votre interview qui est à
retrouver ce matin dans les colonnes du
même livre merci beaucoup merci Fabrice
bonne semaine on passe au club des
territoires